[Musique]
bonsoir bonsoir à toutes et à tous
bienvenue sur le plateau de sciences
publiques votre rendez-vous de débat de
reportage et d'expertise sur Public
Sénat on est ensemble tous les jours du
lundi au jeudi à 18h et 22h pour donner
du sens à l'actualité et voici le
sommaire de ce 28 septembre porno
l'enfer du décor c'est le titre d'un
rapport sénatorial publié ce matin par 4
sénatrices qui dénoncent la
recrudescence de contenu dans de plus en
plus trash et violent un rapport qui
fait suite à l'enquête pour viol lancer
contre les sites French boukak et
Jacquie et Michel que peuvent faire la
justice et les pouvoirs publics pour
nettoyer un business gagné par la
violence ce sera notre premier débat
juste après ces titres et puis dans 45
minutes on va décortiquer la réforme de
la police judiciaire plusieurs grands
flics et magistrats si oppose ils
craignent de voir disparaître la PJ et
ils ont reçu le soutien inattendu du
comédien Gérard Lanvin
il y a plus de mots c'est supprimer la
PJ quoi
contre la connerie mon soutien les amis
pour justifier cette réforme le ministre
de l'Intérieur pointe le taux
d'élucidation des crimes et délit en
baisse constante depuis 10 ans faut-il
réformer l'APG est-elle vraiment menacée
de disparition de nos experts en
débattrons tout à l'heure
mais d'abord ce que dévoile le Sénat sur
le monde du porno et ce que propose ce
rapport pour encadrer une industrie
prédatrice Jérémy harrisman
six mois de travaux des dizaines
d'heures d'audition et un rapport
alarmant la délégation au droit des
femmes du Sénat dressent un tableau très
sombre de l'industrie du porno gangrené
selon les sénatrices par une violence
systémique envers les femmes l'industrie
pornographique aujourd'hui elle est
indissociable des violences 90% des
scènes qui sont montrées sont des scènes
de violence non simulées chantage
emprise acte sexuel forcé violent de
soumission le rapport dénonce des
conditions de tournage déplorables et
des méthodes de recrutement ciblant des
femmes précaires et fragiles
la culture du viol c'est soumettre les
femmes et ça s'apparente énormément à ce
qu'on voit au niveau de la prostitution
des pratiques devenues des normes et
diffusées aujourd'hui massivement via
les plateformes réseaux sociaux ou
messagerie privée chaque mois en France
19 millions de personnes visitent un
site pornographique pour les sénatrices
il y a donc urgence elle propose 23
recommandations pour imposer la lutte
contre les violences pornographiques
dans le débat public faciliter les
suppressions de contenu illicites et le
droit à l'oubli et protéger les mineurs
en appliquant la loi sur l'interdiction
d'accès parmi les mesures évoquées la
création d'un délit d'incitation à la
violence sexuelle qui pourrait
sanctionner les plateformes de diffusion
nous voulons que
ce
encer la violence sexuelle figure
également dans le code pénal et plus
s'appliquer à des vidéos qui montrent le
viol l'humiliation les violences
sexuelles comme étant la norme de la
sexualité un rapport destiné aussi à
alerter les pouvoirs publics et
constituer selon les sénatrices une base
pour un futur texte de loi
faut-il interdire le porno est-ce
possible autant des plateformes et des
sites basés à l'étranger en en débat
tout de suite avec Annick billon bonsoir
vous êtes sénatrice du groupe Union
centriste président de la délégation au
droit des femmes et co rapporteur de ce
rapport sur l'industrie de la
pornographie j'accueille également
Thierry chaffhauser bonsoir bienvenu
vous êtes travailleur du sexe syndiqué
au strass syndicat du travail sexuel
acteur de films pornographiques Samuel
comblese bonsoir
psychologue de l'enfance et de
l'adolescence directeur des opérations
de l'association y enfance 30-18 tout à
fait c'est une ligne d'écoute et le 30
18 on va rappeler ce numéro et on le
dira plusieurs fois tiens dans
l'émission Le 30 18
j'accue également avec nous en duplex
relatharissique et grand reporter à
complément d'enquête bonsoir bienvenue
vous êtes réalisatrice de l'enquête le
porno sera-t-il bientôt interdit que
sera diffusé demain soir sur France 2 et
Mathieu croissanto éditorialiste
politique bonsoir Mathieu alors la
question de l'interdiction ça va être un
peu le fil rouge de ce de ce débat mais
avant ça il y a peut-être ce constat de
violence vous vous pointez dans votre
rapport 90% des scènes pornographiques
comporte de la violence Annick billon
est-ce que vous attendiez à un tel
constat déjà on s'attendait pas à ce
constat ce qu'on a pu voir au cours de
ces 6 mois de travail c'est dizaines
d'heures d'audition c'est que au cours
de ces 15 dernières années la
pornographie l'industrie de la
pornographie a évolué considérablement
avec une massification des contenus une
massification de la diffusion et une
massification de la consommation donc on
s'attendait à ce que ce soit un sujet
peut-être même au départ on pensait que
la protection des mineurs allaient nous
occuper entièrement et on s'est aperçu
que au-delà de la protection des mineurs
qui est un sujet majeur il y avait
évidemment la question des contenus la
question de la production de ces
contenus la question en réalité de cette
pornographie qui est depuis une
quinzaine d'années depuis l'arrivée des
chaînes tubes disp H24 partout
gratuitement sans qu'il y ait aucun
contrôle et surtout que ces entreprises
qui je le dis devant un travailleur du
sexe ces entreprises qui qui on aurait
pu croire était une affaire de sexe en
réalité c'est une affaire de finance
c'est une affaire de business c'est une
usine à faire de l'argent et que les
personnes qui sont derrière ces pornhub
c'est youporn c'est tous ces sites ces
chaînes finalement ils n'ont rien à voir
avec le sexe ils ont à voir avec la
finance d'ailleurs il se trouve
majoritairement dans des paradis fiscaux
donc c'est une industrie extrêmement
opaque et difficile à contrôler
évidemment et ce business il repose sur
des consommateurs je rappelle le titre
qu'on a entendu dans dans le sujet à
l'instant 19 millions de consommateurs
uniques de sites pornos chaque mois en
France je reste sur la question de la
violence avec vous Thierry chaffozer
peut-être ça fait combien de temps que
vous faites ce métier et est-ce que vous
voyez
des contenus violents ou des demandes
des scènes plus violente qu'avant ça
c'est la première partie de la question
et elle est liée est-ce que ce chiffre
de 90% de scènes pornographiques qui
comporte de la violence vous vous le
ressentez vous le vivez au quotidien ou
pas du tout voilà en ce qui concerne le
porno moi j'ai fait entre une quinzaine
et une vingtaine de films et j'estime
que les films que j'ai fait ne sont pas
violents en fait donc je pense que
peut-être un problème de comment on
définit la violence d'ailleurs il y a
l'expression violence prostitutionnelle
violence pornographique que je découvre
comme nouveau concept mais je pense
qu'il faudrait peut-être le définir et
le chiffre de 90% pareil je ne sais pas
d'où il vient je pense qu'il y a pas de
il y a un problème en fait de manque de
méthodologie c'est un chiffre qui n'est
pas soutenu scientifiquement parlant et
je pense que bon même si on a l'habitude
que les politiques nous mentent en fait
là on a un exemple supplémentaire à
travers ce rapport de chiffres qui sont
sans base scientifique et qui sont des
purement songes et ça en fait la lecture
du rapport moi je pensais qu'on le but
c'était lutter contre les violences
contre l'exploitation pour les mauvaises
pratiques dans l'industrie
pornographique en fait en lisant le
rapport je me rends compte qu'en fait
non c'est simplement une croisade morale
de plus le titre est assez vocateur
d'ailleurs puisqu'on a tout le
vocabulaire religieux dans le titre et
en fait le but c'est de prohiber la
pornographie et donc là on est plus du
tout dans la protection des personnes et
je pense même que c'est contre-productif
si on veut vraiment être efficace à ce
moyen une chose très marquante que je
que qui m'étonne dans ces 50 pages de
rapport c'est qu'on parle pas une seule
fois du droit du travail alors que comme
vous le disent c'est une question de
finance c'est pas une question de sexe
évidemment on parle d'autre moi je veux
qu'on parle de travail mais en fait il y
a rien là-dessus alors même que mes
concerts actrices et productrices ont
été auditionnés elles ont parlé de ça
elles ont parlé de convention collective
ils ont parlé droit du travail etc en
fait ça ne se retrouve pas dans ce je
vais vous donner la parole dans un
instant mais comme vous dites ça ça
démarre fort d'une certaine façon sur la
violence puisque là vous mettez en cause
en fait
ce chiffre proposé par les sénatrices
dans ce rapport comment vous arrivez à
ce style de 90% déjà je voudrais revenir
sur les propos de Monsieur qui qui dit
on nous ment non on nous ment pas on
vous ment pas pardon c'est que nous
avons entendu tous les protagonistes
pour ce travail la protection de
l'enfance les acteurs les actrices oui
qui nous ont parlé de charte éthique de
de coordinateurs d'intimité nous avons
entendu des psychologues des chercheurs
des scientifiques des professionnels de
la médecine et ce rapport il est surtout
un condensé de tout ce qui a été dit si
on le lit si on lit les 150 pages de
tout ce qui a été dit
redonner intégralement dans la manière
dont ça a été dit dans ce rapport donc
non nous ne mentons pas oui il peut
exister de la pornographie heureuse mais
ce que nous disons éthique comme on dit
mais ce que nous disons est d'ailleurs
vous le dites vous-même vous avez tourné
quelques films mais toutes les minutes
ce sont des millions de vues de vidéos
qui circulent sur le net et on sait très
bien que la part de la pornographie
éthique elle est très faible par rapport
au reste évidemment parce que les lieux
tours nage ils sont à l'international
c'est à dire que monsieur fait 15 15
vidéos c'est ça ce que vous avez dit je
crois donc
15 et 20 films voilà sur 15 et 20 films
il y a des millions vous êtes syndiqués
enfin vous représentez un syndicat donc
vous parlez de seulement de votre
expérience effectivement il y a
plusieurs personnes concernées on était
centaines de membres
j'ai plus la référence exacte mais il y
a le chiffre qui est accolé avec
l'organisme qui a donné cette
statistique il faudra que je vous le
retrouve
effectivement une association
prohibitionniste qui n'est pas une
source scientifique en fait alors c'est
une industrie opaque vous l'avez bien
compris non nous ne mentons pas oui nous
avons réalisé que il y avait de la
pornographie qui pouvait être on va dire
acceptable et qui se conformer à des au
respect de l'égalité au respect la
personne mais globalement ce que je vous
ai dit dans mon propos c'est qu'il y a
des millions de vues et que cette
mastication de la consommation amène
finalement une consultation avec les
smartphones avec les ordinateurs qui
fait que la demande elle n'est plus sur
le porno éthique entre guillemets nous
on n'a pas voulu parler de porno éthique
la demande elle se fait sur le porto
alors non hard et trash alors justement
je reste sur cette question là vous
dites ça met le comble est-ce que il
faut pas dire la pornographie mais les
pornographies pourquoi bah c'est vrai
que quand on regarde un petit peu les
les thématiques qui sont proposées par
ces sites internet on est parfois
surpris de de effectivement du côté très
trash de des films qui sont proposés
avec des films qui font la promotion de
l'inceste par exemple avec des sites des
films qui proposent des films zoophiles
scatophile des films avec des femmes
amputées avec des femmes enceintes alors
là on parle beaucoup de la violence des
images je pense que et c'est ce que je
représente ici c'est la protection de
l'enfance bien sûr que les images
peuvent être violentes et je pense que
elles sont d'autant plus violentes quand
on n'est pas prêt à pouvoir les
accueillir et les enfants ne sont
psychiquesment psychiquement après
pardon à les accueillir c'est d'ailleurs
pour ça que ces images sont interdites
avant 18 ans c'est justement pour
pouvoir les protéger parce que
aujourd'hui ils sont confrontés à une
représentation de la sexualité qui n'est
pas la représentation
qu'on aurait envie de leur transmettre
en tout cas pas la sexualité adulte
qu'ils vont devoir réaliser quand ils
seront une majeurs et c'est vrai que
cette cette pluralité de thématique je
pense apportent énormément d'angoisse
pour les enfants parce que leur
représentation c'est que la sexualité
des adultes c'est celle que les sites
internet proposent et c'est vrai qu'il y
a besoin de les accompagner évidemment
et on évoquera les moyens d'ailleurs
existe-t-il vraiment pour contrôler
enfin souvent du contrôle parental sur
les smartphones est-ce que ça marche pas
bref on en parlera évidemment largement
ensemble je voudrais vous entendre
relater ici
peut-être sur cette question de violence
on au fil de l'enquête le vous avez
vraiment travaillé sur le le dossier
l'affaire de ce site French boukake donc
mais mais sur ce constat de la violence
est-ce que vous qui avez enquêté
longuement sur sur l'industrie du film
porno est-ce que vous le faites aussi
est-ce que vous avez le sentiment que
elle est plus présente dans les films
que il y a quelques années
très clairement oui pour le coup moi je
rejoins totalement
Sion et en effet nous sur le dans
l'enquête sur laquelle j'ai travaillé la
violence est omniprésente vraiment
vraiment partout et effectivement j'ai
eu l'occasion de regarder énormément de
sites pour me documenter pour pouvoir
comparer etc et c'est vrai que la
violence verbale physique les insultes
les crachats sont vraiment vraiment
omniprésents et pareil je n'ai pas le
chiffre en tête mais en effet je crois
que j'avais quelque chose qui enfin
j'avais un chiffre qui disait que ça
avait énormément augmenté par rapport au
je sais pas au 20 dernières années je
crois alors pour prendre conscience de
cette violence et c'est pas évident un
débat comme comme celui-là parce que il
faut à la fois
dire les choses voilà parfois être cru
dans la façon de le dire et puis en même
temps ne pas être dans une forme de
complaisance justement sur le les scènes
dont on va parler mais je vous propose
pour prendre conscience d'entendre un
témoignage dans toute sa crudité d'une
des femmes victimes dans cette affaire
French ou Kake c'est un extrait du
documentaire de Fabien Requet qui sera
diffusé sur le 8 octobre prochain cette
jeune femme elle fait partie des 43 qui
portent plainte dans ce dossier et ce
qu'elle dit c'est difficile à entendre
encore une fois voilà c'est aussi un
message de mise en garde que je fais à
noter les spectateurs avant la diffusion
de cet extrait son histoire elle est
comme celle de beaucoup d'autres elle
est tombée dans le piège d'un rabatteur
que c'était passé pour une femme sur
Facebook dans quelle pensait participer
à un film tourné par une femme ensuite
voici ce qui lui est arrivé
on est en pleine campagne dans une
maison quasi vide
et de là en fait on
donc avec eux des hommes je crois qu'ils
étaient quatre donc Pascal obéir son
associé deux autres personnes si j'ai
pas de bêtises et j'étais la seule la
seule femme Pascal opé me ramène un
papier en me disant que c'est mon
Tinguette c'est ton contrat enfin c'est
pour l'image et il me fait signer le
papier sans même que je puisse le lire
en gros il me presse énormément et donc
en fait de la
mes viole commence
j'explique que moi il y a pas de sodomie
il y a pas de double pénétration il y a
pas tout ça et ils essayent tant bien
que mal d'essayer de me faire une
sodomie ils essayent de Me de me faire
une pénétration vaginale et d'ailleurs
ils y arrivent
Pauline décrit deux jours de calvaire et
5 scènes ultra-violes avec plusieurs
hommes en Normandie puis en région
parisienne il y a toujours en fait cette
vulnérabilité financière qui fait que je
me dis je ne peux pas repartir sans cet
argent et aussi ce fait que d'après moi
d'après ce qu'il m'a d'après ce qu'il
m'a dit j'ai signé un contrat donc du
coup il y a un contrat qui nous relie
donc je dois finir
ils m'ont tous vu pleurer il y a
personne qui s'est dit non moi je peux
pas la toucher parce qu'elle pleure ils
ont tous continué ils ont tous dit
qu'ils allaient m'achever comme si en
fait j'étais c'est comme si c'était une
chasse à cour et que j'étais un je sais
pas une biche qu'il fallait qu'il
fallait achever en fait il fallait
m'achever
et à ce moment-là je me rappelle que je
regardais la fenêtre qui est en face de
moi en me disant t'inquiète c'est la
dernière tu prends ton argent et tu pars
et
c'est fini alors que 7 ans après c'est
toujours pas fini
vous avez enquêté sur cette affaire
French boukake comment ces femmes
ont-elles été piégées est-ce qu'il y a
une sorte de de mode opératoire en
quelque sorte
là on parle précisément de cette affaire
French [__] pas forcément de des
autres affaires en cours en tout cas sur
cette histoire c'est un homme qui se
faisait passer pour une jeune femme donc
il se faisait qu'il y avait pirater le
facebook d'une jeune mannequin
américaine et qui comme ça aller sur
internet et trouver des jeunes femmes en
leur disant tu es très belle alors
effectivement c'était des jeunes femmes
dont il avait vu qu'elles étaient plutôt
jeunes plutôt jolies et puis en fait en
chatant en discutant il se rendait
compte qu'elles étaient dans des
situations de précarité et il faut leur
faisait croire qu'elle pouvait quand
même gagner énormément d'argent en se
prostituant et en se disant dans des
films pornographiques et donc la plupart
des jeunes femmes parce que je les ai
eus au téléphone je les ai même filmé
etc disent je ne veux pas je ne veux pas
c'est vraiment pas mon
c'est pas mon style et en fin de compte
au fur et à mesure donc la jeune femme
continue leur dire je gagne beaucoup
d'argent c'est facile tu verras ça ne
fera pas diffuser en France etc et petit
à petit le piège se referme c'est à dire
qu'il y a une première on va dire une
première séquence où en fait il leur
fait croire qu'elles vont et qu'elles
vont enfin elles vont se prostituer en
fait donc elle se prostituent et elles
ne sont jamais payées mais quelque part
il y a un tabou qui est brisé c'est à
dire qu'elles ont déjà eu un rapport
sexuel pour de l'argent donc elles n'ont
pas la à l'argent donc elles sont encore
plus endettés et là la fameuse Axelle
revient dans circuit et leur dit mais
t'inquiète pas ça va aller je vais
t'aider tu adores faire tu vas
participer à un film pornographique
c'est juste un homme c'est juste une
fois personne ne le saura c'est un site
confidential au Canada et tout et là en
effet ce que décrit la jeune femme là de
votre documentaire c'est effectivement
exactement ce que j'ai recueilli aussi
comme témoignage j'en ai eu plusieurs au
téléphone là c'est plusieurs hommes
c'est des pratiques quand on dit acte de
torture et de barbarie moi j'ai vu des
scènes elles m'ont montré
des vidéos c'est il y en a une qui
saigne qui pleure personne s'arrête il y
en a une qui supplie d'arrêter ils sont
plusieurs tout le monde rit tout le
monde rit enfin c'est vraiment vraiment
très très difficile et tout ça pour dire
que ces jeunes filles en fait elles ont
été recrutées parce qu'elles étaient
fragiles je crois qu'en plus il y en a
certains qui recrutaient enfin en tout
cas le rabatteur là dans des milieux HDF
dans des milieux toxicomanes dans des
milieux des scores et donc tout ça pour
dire que finalement on a l'impression
que en tout cas pour cette affaire il y
a quand même une cinquantaine de
victimes présumées c'est on a vraiment
vraiment choisi ces jeunes femmes parce
qu'elles étaient en situation de
précarité de fragilité autant financière
que psychologique et donc ça c'est quand
même vraiment très très difficile à
accepter dans notre société bien sûr et
la question qu'on peut se poser
maintenant c'est la question de notre
arsenal législatif pour protéger ces
jeunes femmes pour empêcher que de tel
tournage se déroule Thierry chaoser
est-ce que justement vous pensez qu'on a
parce que je rappelle que vous êtes
représentant syndical qu'on a dans nos
textes suffisamment
législatives pour empêcher ça
alors je pense que effectivement au
niveau pénal il y a beaucoup de il y a
beaucoup de lois qui qui vise à
condamner les violences mais je crois
qu'en fait ce qui nous manque
aujourd'hui quand on analyse ce problème
des violences dans l'industrie c'est que
on est effectivement dans une entreprise
qui a beaucoup évolué ces dernières
années aujourd'hui en fait le problème
qu'on évoque pas en fait c'est le
problème de la sous-traitance c'est à
dire que les il y a pas de
déjà le le la relation salariale est
rarement reconnue c'est à dire qu'on a
souvent des contrats commerciaux de
cessation de droit à l'image mais très
peu de contrats à proprement parler de
travail et donc les obligations
patronales des producteurs des
employeurs en fait souvent son ne sont
pas respectés alors que c'est un une
base c'est quand même la sécurité et la
santé sur le lieu de travail ça devrait
être une obligation patronale et en fait
la sous-traitance permet aussi de se
déresponsabiliser en particulier auprès
de toutes ces je les appelle même pas
producteur mais ça en fait des hommes
qui vont faire collecter des images pour
ensuite les revendre aux producteurs et
distributeurs et c'est dans ce contexte
là où on voit bien que comme il y a
aucune norme aucune règle et ben on a
les pires abus qui se commettent mais je
pense que vous dites
mais le producteur qui peut-être n'a pas
tourné lui-même ses images il a quand
même la responsabilité de les acheter et
de les diffuser ça ne retient rien ça
responsabilité de diffusion continue
complètement d'accord avec vous le
problème c'est que beaucoup essayez de
se défausser le responsabilité donc moi
je pense que l'enjeu il est là aussi
c'est de faire appliquer le droit le
droit du travail et de dire que en fait
c'est pas parce qu'on se traite à ce
genre de personne que en fait on a plus
de responsabilité et quand il y a des
chartes qui se créent est-ce que ces
chartes on va leur dire ridic pour
l'instant alors certaines productions
ensuite
inclut l'écharte dans les contrats donc
peut-être que les ont une valeur
juridique mais enfin c'est aussi ça la
question c'est il faut que ce soit
contraignant je vous donne la parole
tout de suite mais relate artistique je
vous vois sur mon écran de contrôle en
train de de faire signe vous les réagir
allez-y
oui alors justement vous parlez
d'Arsenal juridique alors dans cette
affaire il y a au moins cinq jeunes
femmes qui ont essayé de porter plainte
pour viol il y en a une à qui on a dit
que c'était un litige commercial donc
elle a essayé de dire je voilà je me
suis fait violer il y en a une deuxième
qui est allée aussi il y en a 5 donc
c'est quand même énorme et en fait
toutes les plantes ont été classées sans
suite on leur a dit bah c'est pas
matérialisé vous êtes actrice de films
pornographiques vous avez pas pu vous
faire violer donc elles ont pourtant les
vidéos étaient en ligne donc en fait
quand vous voyez les vidéos les filles
pleurent il y a pas l'ombre d'un doute
quand les gendarmes d'après mes
informations ont vu les vidéos vous
voyez bien que qu'elle pleure et qu'elle
ne joue pas la comédie ou en tout cas
quand elles essayent de porter plainte
ce qu'on ne comprend pas c'est qu'est-ce
comment c'est possible que notre société
ne soit pas capable de prendre au
sérieux ses plantes et de se dire bah
tiens une actrice de films
pornographiques elle peut aussi se faire
violer et le consentement existe aussi
dans ce milieu là c'est important de de
le préciser anibis on ces femmes qui qui
portent plainte dans l'affaire vous les
avez pour certaines auditionnés à huis
clos c'est ça
et c'est pour ça que j'ai un peu de mal
à entendre lorsqu'on nous accuse de
mensonges parce que cette audition à
huis clos elle a été profondément
éprouvante parce que là c'est qu'une
partie des violences et de la barbarie
qu'elles ont subi je peux vous assurer
que l'avocate qui écoutait le témoignage
d'une autre qui cliente d'une autre
avocate elle était en pleurs pendant
l'audition tellement les termes de
récits étaient absolument barbares des
actes de torture qu'elles ont vécu ces
femmes et merci d'avoir pris ce
témoignage parce que oui il y a de la
porno mais faut se dire aussi que ce
sont les femmes majoritairement qui sont
qui subissent toutes ces violences dans
les films pornographiques de la
pornographie ce sont rarement les hommes
en réalité de classe j'entends ça c'est
sur le le les conditions on va dire des
auditions et sur l'aspect législatif sur
le fait que ce que nous disait voilà
Tarse ici à l'instant c'est-à-dire que
bon ben vous êtes actrice porno donc
finalement vous pouvez tout subir quoi
c'est quand même je mets pas en doute le
témoignage de ma concerne les
légendaires n'ont pas fait leur travail
quoi la seule chose c'est que et c'est
pour ça que ça fait partie du premier
volet des recommandations qu'on porte
avec les trois autres rapporteurs c'est
qu'il faut imposer le sujet de la
pornographie dans le débat public et
c'est à dire que là où la société avait
du mal auparavant à imaginer un viol
conjugal il faut que la société se rende
compte aujourd'hui qu'il y a possibilité
d'avoir des viols dans la pornographie
et que le constantement il doit être
réversible à tout moment donc on le voit
bien les contrats qui étaient demandés
nous n'avons pas porté la voie
réglementariste parce que ben on a bien
vu dans les affaires en cours notamment
puisque c'est des gens qu'on avait
auditionné aussi dans certaines affaires
qui s'enorgueillissaient d'avoir mis en
place un certain nombre de verrous ces
verrou ne tenait pas en réalité le
témoignage le démontre on leur fait
signer un bout de papier il y a une
générosité entre porno proxénétisme
prostitution et au final il y a ce viol
de soumission au départ qui permet
ensuite de passer toutes les étapes donc
c'est à dire un chantage à la fois sur
ces personnes en situation de
vulnérabilité donc il y a un repérage et
c'est pour ça que dans ces affaires
d'ailleurs les les
plaintes sont par rapport à du
proxénétisme violent et
ce qui suit donc c'est des jeunes femmes
qui ne sont pas actrices en fait qui
sont des dans une grande précarité
est-ce que vous avez eu des témoignages
de violence aussi de la part de
comédienne ou d'actrices
professionnelles c'est à dire qu'ils
font carrière dans ce dans ce cinéma là
est-ce qu'il y a aussi des violences
dans les films j'allais dire plus
professionnel on a eu des témoignages
d'actrices la seule chose c'est que les
témoignages d'actrices que nous avons eu
c'était des actrices qui tournaient des
films à la marge nous n'avons pas eu de
témoignages d'actrices
[Musique]
et ces images souvent ils sont piégés je
dirais à l'intérieur de leur souvenir
ils ne peuvent pas élaborer un discours
qui leur permettrait justement de se
rassurer vous savez une des premières
choses que qu'un enfant pense quand il
regarde des films pornographiques c'est
mes parents font la même chose et moi
j'ai des jeunes patients qui m'ont déjà
posé cette question là rassurez-moi et
dites-moi que ce que j'ai vu dans ces
films pornographiques mes parents n'ont
pas les mêmes pratiques et c'est normal
qu'ils se posent la question parce que
personne ne peut les rassurer parce que
souvent ça se fait effectivement dans
l'intimité d'une chambre d'adolescence
sur un téléphone ou une tablette et et
ce qu'il faut entendre je crois quand on
sait que beaucoup d'enfants et
d'adolescents et de plus en plus
malheureusement regardez des images
pornographiques c'est qu'il faut
entendre que ils cherchent des réponses
à leurs questions ils se questionne sur
la sexualité et comme aujourd'hui en
France les adultes ont un petit peu de
mal à parler de sexualité parce que ils
ont peur de de trop parler de leur
intimité parce qu'ils ont peur d'avoir à
faire face à des des questions quelle
ligne serait pas répondre et bien les
enfants se tournent vers une source qui
nous imaginent fiables gratuites facile
d'accès
quels sont les films pornographiques
dont on parle là et juste avant ce qu'on
disait c'est que la matorise avec lequel
parfois les images sont tournées je
dirais apporte aussi une nouvelle
dimension à la pornographie accessible
aux mineurs parce que cet amateurisme
accentue encore plus le fait que ce
qu'il voit dans les images c'est la
réalité des couples aujourd'hui en
France et que c'est comme ça qu'il faut
agir et moi je suis très étonné très
inqui aussi parfois quand des
adolescents ou des jeunes enfants me
parlent de leur représentation de la
sexualité et bien en fait il me
décrivent un scénario de films
pornographiques c'est très codifié un
film pornographique et j'ai l'impression
enfin je le ressens les adolescents en
fait collent exactement à ce à se
dérouler avec des décès enfin des
rapports sexuels qui doivent durer très
longtemps des rapports sexuels dans
lesquels on ne peut pas parler dans
lequel il y a pas de protection avec
effectivement une soumission de la part
de de la partenaire féminine qui qui est
vraiment très présente et c'est vrai
qu'ils ont ils ont du mal à déconstruire
ces représentations et je pense que
enfin on en parlera tout à l'heure mais
je pense que de pouvoir sensibiliser
justement les enfants à la sexualité est
important pour lutter contre ces
phénomènes un autre témoignage celui de
Céline piqué porte-parole de
l'association
osez-le féminisme elle a également été
entendue par votre mission d'information
à écouter là
les vidéos qui sont le plus recherchées
sur ces plateformes sont celles qui ont
par exemple hashtag mot clé fantasme
familial step father father donc c'est
vraiment des vidéos dans lequel le
scénario est un scénario
incestueur ou pédocrinel et puis la
dernière chose que je voulais souligner
qui est extrêmement présent sur les
plateformes pornographiques c'est
l'apologie de la haine raciale
Thierry chaffhauser est-ce que le
l'univers qu'on décrit en ce moment là
depuis bientôt une demi-heure dans ce
débat c'est celui que vous connaissez
c'est ce que celui que je connais dans
la société en général c'est à dire je
pense que le sexisme le racisme est
discrimination c'est présent dans
beaucoup d'industrie dans l'industrie du
cinéma en général donc moi je sais pas
on pourrait dire que je pense à
l'actrice adelenelle qui a protesté
contre la récompense remise à Polanski
lors d'une cérémonie est-ce qu'on a
est-ce qu'on va dire qu'il faut
interdire le cinéma parce que dans le
cinéma il y a du sexisme il y a des
représentations violentes de viol mais
dans le cinéma aussi il y a du viol en
fait même dans le journalisme il y a des
femmes qui ont été victimes de viol de
la part de PPD par exemple est-ce qu'on
va interdire le journalisme non je pense
que quelqu'un
qui mélangent un peu aujourd'hui c'est
plutôt ici autour de la table des
personnes qui font des amalgames entre
tout et n'importe quoi c'est ce que
j'entends parler proxénétisme
pornographie viol etc
c'est pas moi qui les font
on essaye de savoir systémique ou pas
c'est à dire que ce mode opératoire
qui est faite de la pornographie comme
quelque chose qui serait différent du
reste de la société les fantasmes et les
et les représentations dont on parle
elles sont présentes partout dans le
cinéma classique également sauf que les
solutions comme par exemple c'est pas
les mêmes et là on voit bien qu'on est
sur un agent d'un prohibitionniste qui
en fait va être contre-productif parce
que quand parce qu'en fait je pense que
la situation actuelle où on a ses abus
on a ces mauvaises pratiques c'est
justement parce qu'on a difficulté
d'accès au niveau du droit et qui est
d'ailleurs lié à la stigmatisation moi
je trouve qu'effectivement c'est pas
normal qu'en étiquita Bellucci explique
elle a dû faire cinq commissariats pour
pouvoir porter plainte effectivement ça
c'est une réalité renforcée quand on y
travaille du sexe parce qu'il y a une
stigmatisation supplémentaire c'est un
sexisme ce qui est encore plus fort mais
du coup la solution c'est quoi la
solution c'est peut-être justement de
lutter contre cette exceptionnalisation
et cet espace hors du droit commun parce
qu'on m'accuse d'être réglementariste
moi je suis pas du tout réglementariste
au contraire je veux le droit commun je
veux pas de disposition spécifique comme
on sait qu'on essaie de nous le proposer
parce que je pense que ça va ajouter
encore plus de stigmatisation et de
discrimination c'est pas une exception
on l'a dit la majorité des demandes sur
le net sont des demandes de violence de
porno gonzo comme c'est appelé et
aujourd'hui
véritablement le porno éthique
n'intéresse personne n'intéresse
personne c'est ça la réalité la réalité
c'est aussi les addictions c'est à dire
que plus vous avez 20 millions 19
millions exactement de connexion unique
par mois ça veut dire que quand même
nous avons un certain nombre de
personnes qui consomment régulièrement
de la pornographie et que à travers
cette consommation excessive ils sont en
demande et ça a été prouvé
médicalement avec les personnes que nous
avons auditionné qui a un phénomène
d'addiction il y a d'ailleurs dans des
services hospitaliers il y a des
personnels désormais qui vont s'attacher
à déconstruire ces addictions donc ce
qu'il faut dire absolument c'est qu'il
faut porter le débat public sur la
pornographie c'est essentiel pour
pouvoir enfin lutter apporter des
solutions pour les mineurs apporter des
solutions pour bloquer les sites et puis
non le viol ce n'est pas autorisé et
lorsque il y a des personnes comme cette
actrice qui témoignait lorsqu'il y a des
pleurs rien n'est simulé dans ces films
pornos la violence n'est pas simulée le
sang n'est pas simulé la pénétration la
triple pénétration ne sont pas simulés
de faut arrêter de dire que tout va bien
dans le porno donc tout va très mal dans
le porno et les éduquer les générations
que nous sommes en train d'éduquer faute
d'éducation et pourtant c'est inscrit
dans la loi faute d'éducation adaptée
parce que une fois qu'on aura dit on va
faire l'éducation dans les pour les
adolescents il va falloir avoir des
cours d'éducation adaptées
grâce à Alexandre poussa un peu détaillé
ce qui ce qui existe et donc bonsoir
Alexandre on va commencer par rappeler
ce que dit peut-être tout simplement le
code pénal mais oui même si le code
pénal interdit clairement l'exposition
d'images pornographiques aux mineurs de
nombreux sites sont accessibles à nos
enfants en un seul clic et les chiffres
sont effrayant environ 10% des enfants
de moins de 11 ans ont déjà vu des
images pornographiques chez les moins de
13 ans cela concerne un quart des filles
et plus d'un tiers des garçons chez les
moins de 15 ans la proportion passe aux
deux tiers et une grande majorité de
tous les mineurs ont déjà vu ce type
d'images autre chiffre sur les 19
millions de visiteurs mensuels de sites
pornographiques en France et bien il y a
1,2 millions d'enfants de moins de 15
ans et plus d'un million de jeunes entre
15 et 18 ans et cette exposition elle a
des conséquences très nocives vous le
disiez sur la psychologie des enfants on
va écouter la sénatrice Laurence
Rossignol qui est l'une des co-auteurs
de ce rapport sénatorial
des psy qu'on avait auditionné a eu
cette phrase que j'aime bien qui dit la
curiosité pour la sexualité chez les
adolescents est une est un
questionnement sain pour autant le porno
apporte une réponse toxique à une
question saine
des images toxiques et qui peuvent
troubler complètement le rapport de nos
jeunes alors corps à la sexualité et qui
peuvent aussi nous mettre en danger
écouter la sénatrice Alexandra borque
Fontain je crois qu'en tant que parents
on imagine jamais que son enfant peut se
mettre en photo de manière dénudée à 12
ans ou 13 ans et malheureusement sur les
réseaux sociaux que on connaît tous ces
monnaies courantes aujourd'hui quand on
se déplaçait dans certains collèges nous
avons entendu des témoignages de
collégiennes qui étaient en classe de
troisième qui nous disait que certaines
de leurs copines faisaient ça contre de
l'argent donc à tété des marchés sur les
réseaux sociaux
que propose le Sénat pour mieux vraiment
protéger les jeunes de la pornographie
et bien d'abord appliquer enfin la loi
d'interdiction d'exposition de ces
images aux mineurs en augmentant les
moyens de l'arcom le régulateur
d'Internet pour sanctionner les sites
pornographiques accessibles aux enfants
ils font ensuite améliorer les
dispositifs de vérification d'âge à
l'entrée de ces plateformes et puis les
sénateurs proposent de mettre en place
automatiquement un contrôle parental
pour tout abonnement téléphonique qui
serait souscrit pour un mineur ensuite
l'enjeu et bien c'est d'éduquer nos
jeunes pour les protéger par exemple en
abordant ce sujet de la pornographie
dans les cours d'éducation à la vie
sexuelle dans les établissements
scolaires également en recrutant des
professionnels de santé qui sont dédiés
à ces risques dans les collèges les
lycées et puis ensuite il faut
sensibiliser les parents sur cette
question et leur rappeler d'ailleurs
qu'il y a une plateforme d'information
créée par le Gouvernement sur ce sujet
un site internet intitulé je protège mon
enfant point gouv.fr merci beaucoup je
protège mon enfant point gouv point fr
je reviens vers vous évidemment ça met
le comblée sur le cette idée je pense
aux parents qui nous regardent au
grand-parents qui parfois garde leur
petit enfant après l'école ou qui vont
les accueillir en vacances là dans dans
quelques jours et qui se sente
complètement démunis
quels outils ont-ils pour limiter
l'accès aux images porno à ses enfants
ou à leurs enfants leurs petits-enfants
on parle souvent du du contrôle parental
moi j'ai l'impression que ça on n'y
arrive jamais quoi alors ça va être le
contrôle parental est un logiciel qui
permet de filtrer justement ces contenus
qu'on va adapter évidemment en fonction
de l'âge de l'enfant pour lui laisser
une plus grande liberté au fur et à
mesure qu'il grandit vous avez raison
c'est pas simple ça prend du temps il
faut s'y intéresser prendre le temps de
comprendre comment ça fonctionne et puis
je dirais c'est pas une solution
universelle parce que si vous mettez des
protections au sein de votre foyer mais
que le petit voisin d'à côté n'a pas la
chance d'avoir des parents aussi
prévenant et bien on sait très bien que
les enfants vont aller regarder là où il
y a un trou dans la raquette et c'est à
ce moment-là que l'accès à la
pornographie se donc je ne dis pas pour
autant qu'il ne faut pas utiliser un
contrôle parental au contraire j'aurais
envie de dire mettons sur tout les
terminaux accessibles aux enfants ce
logiciel de contrôle parental d'ailleurs
la loi va évoluer puisque le député
Studer a préconisé qu'il puisse y avoir
une installation automatique dès qu'on
achète un nouveau terminal justement un
téléphone ou une tablette pour
accessible aux enfants pour que ce
logiciel de contreballe soit installé
par défaut mais ça ne fait pas tout
logiciel parental et pour répondre à
votre question quel est le deuxième
outil qu'on peut utiliser c'est la
parole tout simplement c'est la
sensibilisation c'est le fait de
prévenir que tout ce qu'on est en train
de se raconter ce soir ben c'est pas
accessible pour pour un enfant et c'est
d'ailleurs encore pour ceux qui nous
regardent pendant nos interrompre c'est
c'est aller contre leur propre pudeur
d'une certaine façon parce que très
souvent on hésite on sait pas trouver
les mots on se dit qu'est-ce que je vais
dire à mon enfant ou à mon petit enfant
vous voyez ce que c'est là où on a
besoin il faut aller contre ça c'est là
où on a besoin de progresser
collectivement et peut-être d'aider
justement les parents et les éducateurs
au sens large que ce soit les
enseignants les coachs sportifs tous les
gens qui peuvent sensibiliser à un
moment les enfants d'abord quand vous
prenez un petit peu de temps avec un
enfant ou un adolescent de parler de
sexualité vous allez vous rendre compte
d'abord que les gamins vous posent pas
des questions qui vont aller je dirais
sur un sur un terrain interdit ça c'est
une représentation d'adulte les enfants
ils arrivent à rester à leur place et
même si ils étaient un petit peu
aventuriers qu'il vous posait des
questions un peu trop intimes vous avez
le droit en tant qu'adulte de dire bah
ça c'est mon jardin secret c'est aussi
un apprentissage de la sexualité de dire
il y a des choses qui vont appartenir
quand tu seras grand et je ne veux pas
savoir pardon et moi pareil j'ai aussi
mon jardin secret que je vais garder
pour moi ensuite ce qui est intéressant
quand vous commencez à parler de
sexualité c'est de ne pas faire comme on
fait d'habitude en tant qu'adulte à
savoir je sais parce que je suis
l'adulte et je vais t'apprendre parce
que toi tu es un enfant on peut déjà
partir du principe que l'enfant il sait
des choses il a il y a des
représentations il y a peut-être vu des
images pornographiques il entend ses
copains en parler à l'école peut-être
qu'on peut lui dire mais qu'est-ce que
toi tu en connais qu'est-ce que tu sais
de la sexualité pour voir déjà quel est
son niveau de langage quelle est la
facilité avec laquelle il s'exprime et
puis après de voir à quel niveau nous en
tant qu'adulte on peut peut-être
apporter des éléments supplémentaires de
connaissances vous pouvez aussi utiliser
des supports pour parler vous avez des
livres extrêmement bien faits à tous les
âges de la vie dès le plus jeune âge
parce que je pense qu'il faut en parler
très tôt de la sexualité aux enfants
parce que c'est c'est un sujet c'est un
vrai sujet et on le sait pour les
adultes partir de quel âge alors moi je
pense que alors à l'association et
enfance on a fait le choix de parler de
pornographie dès le CP des 6 ans et même
on a de plus en plus de demandes d'en
parler encore plus tôt parce que
malheureusement la pornographie elle
peut parfois être accessible
accidentellement quand on prête son
téléphone portable par exemple à son
enfant bah même avant 6 ans
malheureusement les enfants peuvent être
confrontés
des enfants sont en contact avec des
images pornographiques avant l'âge de 11
ans exactement il faut anticiper et plus
on en parle tout et ça toutes les les
études dans le monde le 10 plus on parle
le taux de sexualité à des enfants plus
tard aura lieu leur premier rapport
sexuel tout simplement parce qu'on va
satisfaire leur satisfaire leur
questionnement et leurs interrogations
et je pense que c'est important de
pouvoir en parler le plus tôt possible
mais encore une fois d'être serein et de
se rendre compte aussi qui a vraiment
une maturité aujourd'hui de la part des
enfants et des adolescents de parler de
ces sujets ils sont prêts et encore une
fois ce qui nous disent c'est si vous
n'êtes pas prêt c'est pas grave mais
nous on va continuer à regarder sur les
sur les sites pornographiques et je
crois que le débat de ce soir montre que
c'est pas la meilleure façon de
s'informer allez on va continuer de
répondre à la question un peu fil rouge
de de ce débat faut-il interdire les
films porno Mathieu on peut dire que
certains de nos élus se la pose depuis
longtemps oui en tout cas c'est pas la
première fois que la pornographie c'est
éruption dans le champ politique
moi j'ai repensé ça m'a fait penser aux
années 70 en gros parce que c'est là la
grande décennie où on a parlé
pornographie dans le champ politique
c'est l'époque qui paraît anti
dolivienne aujourd'hui à Tours le maire
de l'époque qui s'appelait Jean Royer
entame une croisade contre les sex-shops
et les films qu'il il suffit de
pornographique alors je fais tout de
suite une énorme parenthèse ce ne sont
pas les mêmes films pornographiques
qu'aujourd'hui l'industrie du X
n'existait pas en tout cas c'était pas
une cash machine comme aujourd'hui et
puis c'était surtout pas une machine à
broyer les femmes comme aujourd'hui
telles que vous venez de nous le
présenter madame la sénatrice mais en
tout cas lui il est excédé par la
distribution de prospectus publicitaires
à l'époque pour livrer rotique il décide
de créer une commission pour interdire
la projection de film susceptible de
troubler l'ordre public comme mission
locale qui a pas pour mission de
censurer mais de surveiller
explique-t-il alors à une journaliste du
Nouvel Observateur qui est auteur d'un
papier que j'ai retrouvé tout en ironie
parce que c'est aussi ça le regard de
l'époque sur la pornographie comme quoi
ça a changé le regard n'était pas le
même et les productions n'étaient pas la
même encore une fois je le dis et puis
les films interdits par Jean Royer
n'étaient pas les mêmes il voulait à
l'époque même peut-être interdire du
Bunuel c'est vous dire j'envoyais en
tout cas il trouve là un créneau
politique qui correspond à son profil
qui est traditionnaliste qui est très
conservateur il dénonce à longueur
d'interview les déviations pervers se
déferlement de sexe qui pourrit notre
moralité nationale pour lui la
pornographie comme la drogue sont les
aspects d'une seule et même crise celle
de l'oisiveté elle s'attire vite le nom
le surnom de père la pudeur qui lui
collera longtemps la peau ce qui
l'empêchera pas de se présenter en 1974
à la présidentielle il fait un meeting à
Toulouse ou des jeunes manifestants
interrompre à plusieurs reprises en
criant une seule solution la
masturbation il y a une jeune femme qui
danse même seins nus au grand bonheur
des photographes il paraît un peu
ridicule voilà combien reste-t-il faire
la présidentielle en quatrième position
en 1974 alors juste avec 3,17% c'est pas
grand chose mais voilà le problème c'est
que Valéry Giscard d'essaye enfin le
problème le jeune président élu à lui
fait une campagne sur une autre
proposition sur ce sujet celle d'abolir
la censure il dit à l'époque c'est pas
le défenseur de la liberté que je suis
dans cette élection présidentielle qui
doit craindre le cinéma français alors à
l'époque officiellement il y a pas de
censure en France mais il y a un
contrôle dont l'objet essentiel c'est la
protection des mineurs mais beaucoup
voient dans ses décisions on est en
pleine libération sexuelle ces années 70
et puis un pouvoir politique qui se mêle
encore beaucoup de choses y compris dans
l'audiovisuel beaucoup voit des arrières
pensées politiques quand on commence à
vouloir réglementer du coup il y a un
relâchement impulsé par Valéry Giscard
d'Estaing de la censure et qui entraîne
un boom une explosion des films X
rendez-vous compte qu'en 1974 l'année de
sortie d'Emmanuel qui rassemblera quand
même 9 millions de spectateurs Emmanuel
mais sur 520 films distribués en France
il y en a 128 qui s'affichent comme
érotique voire carrément pornographique
c'est l'âge d'or du X en salle mais ça
va pas durer très longtemps mais non
parce que un an plus tard la politique
s'en mêle à nouveau et alors moins sous
l'angle de la morale comme le faisait
Jean Royer mais sous l'angle financier
aussi celui-là
l'âge d'or du X en fait il va durer
qu'un an Jacques Chirac et Premier
ministre décide de légiférer et en 75 il
y a des décrets puis une loi qui
intronisent la fameuse classification x
le cinéma pur Renault subit alors une
taxation plus lourde que les les autres
les autres films c'est mon producteur
ces exploitants ils n'ont pas le droit
aux subventions aux aides publiques il y
a une commission de de contrôle qui qui
censure ou qui contrôle les films les
publicités sur les façades les affiches
dans les cinémas pornographiques ne
peuvent pas représenter de de visuels
mais c'est juste des titres
comme vous l'avez dit monsieur nous
n'allons pas non plus vers la
réglementarité mais nous allons nous
souhaitons que le débat public soit
ouvert qu'on puisse en parler et qu'on
puisse avancer pour les mineurs mais pas
que pour les mineurs parce que les
conséquences que vous avez évoqué par
les mineurs il y a des conséquences
aussi pour les relations hommes femmes
et les relations avec le sexe opposé
dans la société
relatharcissique je vous pose la même
question puisque c'est le titre de votre
enquête le porno sera-t-il bientôt
interdit quelle réponse vous nous donnez
alors effectivement la question je me
pose c'est de quel porno on parle parce
qu'on a l'impression que tout le monde
veut essayer de nous faire croire qu'il
y a un porno propre éthique réglementé
etc et un porno un peu plus amateur etc
moi dans mon enquête je me suis rendu
compte qu'en fait c'était il y a c'était
un monde qui était extrêmement peureux
et finalement c'était les mêmes
interlocuteurs les mêmes acteurs les
mêmes réalisateurs les mêmes producteurs
qu'on trouvait donc en fait l'idée c'est
simplement de déjà de définir ce qu'on
entend par pornographie c'est à dire de
quoi on parle est-ce qu'on parle des
tubes est-ce qu'on parle des films on
parle à tout à l'heure de films éthiques
moi j'en ai tourné des séquences
justement j'ai suivi des réalisatrices
de films éthiques et en fait la plupart
n'en vivent pas elles sont un film
parent il y a vraiment pas de public
donc en fait j'ai l'impression que
finalement à chaque fois on parle de de
pornographie éthique mais finalement
c'est un peu la brindille qui cache la
forêt c'est à dire qu'en fait c'est
toujours les deux trois même
réalisatrices qu'on va mettre en avant
donc non pour moi la pop pornographie
aujourd'hui c'est pas ça c'est la
majorité des choses qu'on trouve merci
beaucoup Thierry chaffhauser le risque
d'interdiction pour vous c'est quoi
c'est qu'il y a un marché parallèle
encore plus difficile à contrôler on
voit bien que c'est déjà compliqué
aujourd'hui oui et puis de toute façon
la prohibition peut avoir plusieurs
formes donc ça peut être sous forme de
taxation ça peut être fort sur de loi
qui vont restreindre l'accès qui vont
restreindre les protections l'accès aux
droits etc et donc pour moi en fait ce
texte c'est complètement provisionniste
et je pense qu'il est pas digne d'un
pays qui se veut démocratique parce
qu'en fait les pays qui criminalisent la
pornographie dans le monde se sont pas
des démocraties en tout cas démocratie
occidentale la pornographie relève de
l'article 10 de la Convention des Droits
de l'Homme donc je pense je vais dire
bon courage parce que vous allez avoir
du mal à l'interdire puisque il y a déjà
des jurisprudences au niveau du droit
qui qui estime que la production
pornographique a le droit d'être relève
de la liberté d'expression en fait et a
le droit d'exister ce que nous a dit à
l'instant les minions ces nouvelles
souhaitait pas interdire la pornographie
votre avis là-dessus pour conclure
Samuel complet la pornographie full
interdire au mineur d'ailleurs la loi le
préconise depuis très longtemps et je
pense qu'il faut faire appliquer la loi
ce qui m'a interpellé dans dans le dans
le rapport du Sénat c'est qu'il y a
plein de choses qui existent déjà il
faut juste les faire appliquer et
notamment toutes ces questions de
d'éducation à la vie sexuelle et
affective dans les établissements
scolaires malheureusement c'est voilà
des textes qui existent il suffit juste
maintenant de les mettre en œuvre et il
faut avancer
là-dessus pour pouvoir protéger un
maximum de d'enfants et merci beaucoup
merci à tous d'avoir participé à ce
débat
relatharistique je rappelle le titre de
votre film de votre enquête qui est
diffusé ce soir sur demain soir pardon
sur France 2 le porno sera-t-il bientôt
Inter